there's a lot of and Dick play here I
got to calm down for a second and I'm
like crossing my legs now I'm getting
hot hello everyone I'm Cole sprous I'm
here with BuzzFeed and we are going to
read some thirst tweets I'm hoping for
something really depraved something that
makes me
think I want Cole sprous to sing into
my pick a song I'm right there karaoke
baby I would let Cole sprouts lick
Danimals off this get the danals then
come on bring it out Co Sprouts could
throw it in any hole just throw it in
the aim is perfect I would blow Cole
sprouts Harder Than a Game Boy
cartridge that one's great that one's
[__] poetry I'm ashamed that I want
Co Sprouts 5 in deep in these Cuts but
it is what it is I like that 5 in very
specific how' you know subtle reminder
that K Sprouse's nostrils are in the
shape of perfect love hearts that's nice
you should see the boogers inside I
wonder what type of glow KL sprous as
Nut could give my skin these are good
these are really good I'm impressed
since when is KL sprows packing cheeks
forever I just don't turn around often
because uh I clap and it makes a lot of
noise it's very distracting that was in
reference to your Instagram as that was
in reference to that photo I posted my
publicist is currently sitting behind
the cameras right now shout out to them
for handling that I'm not going to talk
too much about it sometimes things just
live better without any commentary on
them but go and check it out if you want
I had to turn the likes off of that I
was today years old when I found out
Cole sprous got them Clappers on him no
cap Cole the stallion type thick no kzy
is my childhood ruined or horny do the
two have to be mutually exclusive think
about that
as a gay man I've always striven for the
biggest juiciest BBL busy I can get
that's why this pride month I'm
partnering with coal Sprouts whoa I want
coal Sprouts to eat fried chicken out my
ass digested or undigested it's the real
question okay but I want Cole Sprout and
KJ APPA to Eiffel Tower me call us up
put us in a group chat we can talk about
it we have a price Co sprous has that
whole dead look going on and it makes me
wet I got to I got to calm down for a
second coal Sprouts gives me big
boner thank God and I'm like crossing my
legs now I'm getting hot no hetero but I
would suck the life out of Cole
sprous that one's really good talking
about Cole sprous he's Beauty he's Grace
I want to sit on his face suffocate me H
Cole sprous ising me up do I want to be
him do I want to him do I want to women
who look like him the answer is yes to
all the above my queer identity contains
multitudes it cannot be defined yet
somehow Co Sprout also kind of sums it
all
up that one's big there was a lot of
realizations there there's a lot of
deeper existential questions there I'm
glad to be that confusing I watch
Riverdale because K sprous reminds me
where my ovaries are every time he
smirks I'm all about that Mind and Body
Connection Co sprous has literally
always been the man I most have a brush
on so him with black hair leather jacket
motorcycle literally the kind of person
I find most attractive juge head is so
very hot I would Peg you know the whole
narrative up until that point was it
like I didn't know where the ending was
going was nice I'm trying to Cole sprous
come work this hole Henny that scene
with Betty and juge head Honestly made
me die Cole sprous is so Daddy I'd let
him blow cigarette smoke into my
butthole how do you feel about the daddy
narrative I just figure it's just like
internet talk but um I like how you
asked me about the daddy narrative and
not the blowing smoke into their
butthole that's oh that's normal that
part is normal there's a lot of ass and
Dick play here talk to my therapist
about it thank you guys I got to go to
the bathroom for about 5 to 10 minutes
so unfortunately the video has to stop
but thank you for joining me on this
roller coaster oh yeah and Lisa
Frankenstein is in theaters on February
9th go see it if you want that
weird that weird kind of boner
that strange one the one that'll drive
you to the theaters alone or with a
partner thanks
[Music]
guys